Google says it will look at employees
ideas after a global walkout over its
handling of sexual misconduct claims
nearly 17,000 workers in at least 40
offices all over the world protested
yesterday they're upset about how women
are treated at the tech giant Jamie
yuccas spoke with employees at the
company's headquarters now she's in
Mountain View California with the latest
on this story Jamie good morning good
morning a Google engineer we talked to
after the walkout says employees are now
watching to see how the company responds
before determining what's next
organizers of yesterday's walkout we're
hoping that it prompted a bigger
movement but even they were surprised by
the massive turnout from the home of
Google headquarters in Northern
California to New York and abroad
thousands of employees streamed out of
their offices Thursday in a show of
solidarity on Google to take seriously
claims people who are harassed and
respond to them appropriately and these
not speak from under the rug the protest
comes a week after a New York Times
investigation revealed Google had given
Android co-creator Andy Rubin a 90
million dollar exit package in 2014
that's despite accusations of sexual
misconduct against him which the company
deemed were credible Reuben has denied
the allegations and says the
compensation was exaggerated employees
called the case the latest example of a
culture of complicity and abuse of power
when he do hold ourselves to such high
moral standards especially our our
mantra don't be evil I mean this to me
is the epitome of people around the same
time as the walk out Google CEO sundar
pichai acknowledged the anger and
frustration but moments like this show
that we didn't always get it right and
so we are committed to doing better
walkout organizers have five demands
among them no more forced arbitration in
cases of harassment and discrimination
and end to pay an opportunity inequity
and a better process for reporting
harassment I am incredibly touched by
the turnout incredibly touched by the
friends and allies one of the proudest
days of yes career at the past eight
years google says over the past four
years they have fired 48 people over
sexual harassment claims none of them
were paid out the company says it was
also in support of yesterday's walkout
but business leaders point out that
these workers are not unionized so they
don't have protection and walking out
was a big risk
bianna a big risk but it was important
to hear from the CEO as well yesterday
Jamie thank you